the president is pushing Republican
senators to get on board with the
legislation passed by the house to roll
back Obamacare but key Republicans say
the Senate will not vote on that bill
they plan to create their own version of
health care reform major Garrett is at
the White House with the next act and
the health care drama major good morning
good morning this White House is
obviously okay spiking the ball when it
believes it won remember last week the
White House got angry with Democrats
accusing them of doing that after the
budget passed and some of the
president's spending priorities were not
included well this healthcare touchdown
dance occurred sometime in the first
quarter and if you allow me to extend
the metaphor someone the president's own
team are now trashing his health care
playbook the president achieves
something that no one thought he would
White House chief of staff
Reince Priebus defended president
Trump's premature Rose Garden
celebration back-slapping House
Republicans for passing an Obamacare
repeal Senate Republicans will summarily
ignore I think we were right to give the
Congress an attaboy
in the Rose Garden but we also know that
this is just the beginning it's the
first step Republican senators will not
let the American people down the
president said on Twitter Sunday the
House bill is not going to come before
us but Maine Republican Susan Collins
dismissed the House effort joining
numerous Senate GOP critics of the House
bill the Senate is starting from scratch
we're going to draft our own bill and
I'm convinced that we're going to take
the time to do it right Senate GOP
objections range from cuts to Medicaid
spending for the poor and disabled to
the potential loss of insurance for some
because of pre-existing conditions face
it we're all sort of guessing right now
the White House budget director Mick
Mulvaney would not commit the President
to future Senate changes even in the
face of that massive legislative rewrite
Mulvaney said House Republicans should
sell the bill back home I'd be ecstatic
about going back and saying look here's
what we did here's the process was it
ugly yeah but did we get it done did we
follow through on a promise to repeal in
the house yes Idaho Republican Raul
Labrador did as much and got a town hall
earful
nice because they'll have access to help
the congressman later wrote on Facebook
that response quote wasn't very elegant
congressman Labrador went on to explain
that under the GOP bill people who need
emergency care will still be able to
receive it and therefore Charlie and his
words are unlikely to die thanks major